placebo effekt man denkt man weiß dass
wesentliche egal ob medikamente
homöopathie oder sachen wie kurkuma
aktiv kohle öl ziehen wenn ich etwas zu
mir nehmen oder an wänden und es geht
mir danach besser dann gibt es nicht nur
zwei mögliche erklärungen also entweder
das zeug wirkt oder placebo effekt nein
dahinter steckt noch viel mehr heute
klären wir fünf missverständnisse über
den placebo-effekt die uns zeigen dass
der placeboeffekt gleichzeitig
überschätzt und unterschätzt wird also
macht es euch gemütlich holte den ttc
[Musik]
folgendes wisst ihr wahrscheinlich schon
placebos werden in klinischen studien
eingesetzt wenn man einen wirkstoff
testen will dann bekommt eine testgruppe
ein medikament mit diesem wirkstoff und
die kontrollgruppe bekommt ein
scheinmedikament ohne wirkstoff das
heißt ein placebo denn einige menschen
in dieser placebo gruppe wird es
trotzdem nach der gabe dieses
scheinmedikament besser gehen und eine
gängige erklärung dafür ist der
placeboeffekt das heißt allein die
erwartung dass mir etwas helfen wird
hilft tatsächlich selbst ohne wirkstoff
doch da kommen wir schon zum ersten ist
verständnis wem ist noch eine placebo
besser geht der unterliegt nur dem
placebo-effekt nein da gibt es noch viel
mehr effekt nur ein beispiel ein ganz
einfacher grund warum es jemandem nach
irgendeiner anwendung besser geht ist
zeit wenn ich etwas zu mir nehmen sei es
ein wirksames medikament oder ein
unwirksames boucher mittel dann meistens
genau dann wenn es mir gerade besonders
schlecht geht also zum beispiel bei
einer vorübergehenden erkältung oder
einem chronischen leiden dass in schüben
kommt also wenn es mir gerade
außergewöhnlich schlecht geht dann ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit ziemlich hoch
dass es mir bald wieder gewöhnlich geht
solange etwas zeit vergeht dieses
phänomen nennt sich regression zur mitte
und wurde ganz schön in diesem video
demonstriert von meiner kollegin julie
aus dem club der wissenschaftler die wie
monate
juli versucht hier mit einem würfel
möglichst hohe augen zahlen zu würfeln
und bedient sich dabei eines zauberstab
es der dafür sorgt bei bedarf dass sich
die augenzahl verbessert also erhöht das
heißt immer wenn es schlecht läuft immer
wenn juli eine 1 oder eine 2 würfel
wedelt sie mit dem zauberstab und siehe
da schon werden die augen zahlen
daraufhin höher
zumindest zeigt dass eine mathematische
regte auswertung über eine längere wurf
reihe
doch das hat natürlich nichts mit magie
zu tun sondern einfach nur mit der hohen
wahrscheinlichkeit dass nach einem so
schlechten wurf 1 oder 2 sich die
augenzahl nach oben verbessert für die
medikament heißt das nur weil eine
verbesserung nach einem medikament oder
einem placebo eingetreten ist heißt das
noch nicht automatisch dass diese
verbesserung auch dadurch verursacht
wurde
neben der regression zur mitte gibt es
noch ein paar andere effekte wie zum
beispiel den disbon spies auf deutsch
antwort tendenz response weiß kann
studien verzerren die auf befragungen
berühmt vor allem wenn die befragten
etwas zu geben sollen das
gesellschaftlich nicht akzeptiert ist zb
ob sie illegale drogen konsumieren und
selbst wenn die befragung anonym ist
nein die teilnehmer dazu die sozial
akzeptierte antwort zu geben
und interessanterweise passiert dasselbe
auch bei klinischen studien wenn die
teilnehmer zum beispiel wissen dass sie
ein neues asthma medikament testen dann
neigen sie dazu die antwort zu geben die
die forscher gerne hören würden nämlich
ja es hat geholfen effekte wie
regression zur mitte oder response preis
können dazu führen dass man sowohl die
wirkung eines medikaments als auch den
placebo-effekt überschätzt ok
missverständnis nummer zwei placebo
effekte gibt es bei allen erdenklichen
leiden und krankheiten dieser meta
analyse wurden über 200 klinische
studien zusammengefasst die nicht nur
medikament und placebo verglichen hatten
sondern medikament placebo und gar keine
ursprünglich ging es in den meisten
studien natürlich darum ob das
medikament besser wird als ein placebo
dieses review untersuchte diese daten
aber nun darauf hin ob ein plazebo
besser wirkt als gar nichts
die ergebnisse erst in klinischen
studien das heißt wo echte patienten auf
diese art behandeln und verglichen
werden gab es nur bei sehr wenigen
leiden einem nachweisbaren placebo
effekt wirklich eindeutig war es nur bei
schmerzen und übelkeit zweitens der
placebo effekt war subjektiv größer als
objektiv das heißt wenn man die
patienten befragt dann sagt und viele ja
mir geht es besser aber physiologische
tests zeigten dass nicht unbedingt
beispiel nach einem placebo asthma spray
fühlten sich viele patienten besser aber
eine tatsächliche verbesserung der
atemfunktion konnte man nicht messen und
das führt viele zum nächsten
missverständnis placebo effekt ist nur
einbildung es ist viel abgefahrener pass
oft beispiel das ist mobbing ein
rauschmittel das aber auch als
schmerzmittel für starke schmerzen
zugelassen ist es hat strukturelle
ähnlichkeiten mit heroin bekannte truppe
die in england aber auch als
schmerzmittel zugelassen ist in
bestimmten notfällen chemisch zählen
diese schmerzen in einen stoff dazu den
opioiden die wirken indem sie die opioid
rezeptoren in unserem körper aktivieren
und das hier ist naloxon es könnte von
der struktur her auch ein opioid sein
ihr seht bestimmt auch aus nicht-
chemiker gewisse ähnlichkeiten aber es
wird genau gegenteilig das chemisch so
ähnlich ist blockiert naloxon die opioid
rezeptoren im körper so dass opioide
nicht mehr wirken
damit kann man übrigens auch menschen
mit einer heroin überdosis das leben
retten so in den 70ern machten
wissenschaftler jetzt eine spektakuläre
entdeckung
sie gaben patienten die unter schmerzen
litten schmerz placebos wodurch deren
schmerzen gelindert wurden so weit waren
wir schon gar nicht den patienten jetzt
aber schmerz placebos plus naujoks ohne
die placebos nicht mehr und zwar ist
folgendes passiert man kann opioide
nicht nur ein leben
der körper kann auch eigene opioide
herstellen
körpereigenes schmerzmittel wenn man so
will und genau das passiert wenn man ein
medikament oder placebo einnimmt von dem
man erwartet dass es schmerzen lindert
die körperliche schmerz reaktion ist ja
auch keine einbildung da wären signale
vom rückenmark ins gehirn weitergeleitet
und genau da greifen op wieder ein
sie hemmen diese weiterleitung und
lindern so den schmerz also die wirkung
des placebo effekts gegen schmerzen und
gegen einige andere subjektive symptome
ist echt missverständnis nummer vier der
zehn effekt funktioniert nur über
erwartung unser gegen das verständnis
von placebo effekt ist eine self
filmprofis ihr so wenn mir jemand sagt
dieses medikament lindert schmerzen dann
kann allein diese erwartung
entsprechende körperliche reaktionen
auslösen dabei ist dass nur einer von
drei hauptfaktoren neben der erwartung
spielt auch das
arzt-patienten-verhältnis eine wichtige
rolle zum beispiel zeigen studien dass
allein die wahrgenommene kompetenz
seines behandlers sei es jetzt die
ärztin physiotherapeut oder sonstwer
oder auch ihre positive körpersprache
augen kontakten lächeln dass das allein
schon schmerzen lindern kann genau hier
liegt auch die große stärke der
alternativen medizin deren
vermeintlichen arzneimittel sind zwar
pharmakologisch großer quatsch aber
diese intensiven gespräch mit den
patienten helfen bereits und der dritte
große faktor ist konditionierung man
könnte auch sagen lernen was placebo
effekt kann man trainieren beim
stichwort lernen denken wir oft an einen
bewussten ziemlich anstrengenden prozess
aber neurologisch funktioniert lernen
auch unbewusst über konditionierung
konditionierung kennt ihr noch von
unserem video über slot machines und
drückt auf den knopf wird dafür belohnt
und will dann halt noch mal drücken
wiederholt sich das oft genug ist der
zusammenhang zwischen knopf und
belohnung fest verknüpft und man ist
konditioniert dasselbe prinzip
funktioniert auch mit bestrafungen oder
allgemein unangenehmen konsequenzen
das einfachste beispiel ist dass
geschmacks
version lernen die man zum beispiel
ratten eine neue geschmacksrichtung und
gleichzeitig etwas wovon ihr schlecht
wird dann hat die rate bald keine lust
mehr auf diese geschmacksrichtung noch
krasser ist dieses beispiel von unserer
grafikerin melanie es gibt tatsächlich
ein paar meidet videos die kann ich mir
ganz schlecht angucken
bei mir immer direkt über wird und zwar
liegt das daran dass ich die animiert
habe gezeichnet habe in der zeit als ich
gerade schwanger war also vor allen
dingen der anfangszeit der
schwangerschaft weil da hatte ich echt
mit übelkeit zu kämpfen
und ja wenn ich mir die videos heute
angucke oder auch nur stilles sehe also
nur bilder davon sehe
dasselbe kann auch bei bestimmten
medikamenten passieren dh wenn mein
körper eine tablette mit einer gewissen
wirkung verknüpft kann er auch hier
konditioniert werden und wenn ich
irgendwann die tablette auch ohne
wirkstoff bekomme dann kann mein körper
in bestimmten fällen mit gelernten
mechanismen reagieren klar ein
beeindruckendes beispiel in dieser
studie gab mal raten ein medikament dass
deren immunsystem herunter regelte
zusammen mit dem medikament bekamen sie
eine süßstoff lösung und das wiederholte
mal ein paar mal im medikament im mund
es im rother zusammen mit süßstoff
lösung bekamen wir hatten dann
irgendwann nur diese stoffe lösung also
eine placebo behandlung regelte sich ihr
immunsystem von alleine runter das ist
auch deswegen so krass weil es bei
immunsystem da keine subjektive
komponente gibt es jetzt beim schmerz
also was passiert da körperlich wie muss
man sich das vorstellen wir haben einen
placebo forscher angerufen
professor manfred witowski aus ist
erklärt uns gelernt effektiver placebo
verbundes gehen über tatsächlich in
realen die den insel cortex und der
amygdala weitergeleitet wird in den
körper da findet dass man statt also die
verknüpfung zwischen diesen reizen und
das wird transportiere zum immunsystem
hauptsächlich
um zu sehen ob man diesen effekt mit den
ratten vielleicht auch auf eine
behandlung von patienten übertragen kann
die forscher in der zweite studie durch
uns war diesmal mit menschen das waren
30 patienten die eine
nierentransplantation hinter sich hatten
nach so einer transplantation muss man
lebenslang medikamente nehmen die das
immunsystem hemmen damit man das organ
nicht wieder abstößt die patienten
nahmen jeden morgen und jeden abend ihre
immun hemmenden tabletten und dazu
bekamen sie einen einzigartigen
seltsamen geschmack der diakonie zu der
bereits beim menschen ist grün
eingefärbte air berlin die den personen
die windel geschmack zufügen schmeckt
ganz urig die meisten mögen dort nicht
so richtig also ganz eigenartiger
geschmack das ziel war es den körper zu
konditionieren dass diese seltsame grüne
erdbeermilch verknüpft wird mit einem
gehemmten immunsystem so nach drei tagen
konditionierungen also nach drei tagen
lernen kam jetzt der große test die
patienten nahmen also nach wie vor
morgens und abends ihre tabletten
zusammen mit dem komischen getränk und
jetzt nahm sie zusätzlich tagsüber nur
das getränk zusammen mit einer placebo
tabletten also ohne wirkstoffe können
wir sogar noch die immunfunktion bei
diesen patienten sogar noch verstärken
das heißt insgesamt zeigen die
teilnehmer ein noch stärker dämpft das
immunsystem als ob sie eine höhere dosis
an medikamenten genommen hätten obwohl
die dosis gleich geblieben ist nur die
dosis an grüner erdbeermilch wurde
erhöht mit solchen tricks könnte es
vielleicht möglich sein denn die menge
der applizierten medikamente zu
reduzieren und gleichzeitiger
maximierung der therapeutischen effekte
das wäre natürlich toll vor allem bei
belasteten die medikamenten sowie sie
auch menschen nach einer
organtransplantation nehmen müssen alle
die die medikamente haben unerwünschte
nebenwirkung
und wenn man weniger von den
medikamenten nimmt dann erzählen sich
natürlich auf den neben drucken und
übrigens die patienten in dieser studie
wussten dass sie bei dieser zusätzlichen
einnahme nur ein placebo bekamen sie
wussten ist also auch dieses
missverständnis ist falsch placebos
wirken nur wenn man verarscht wird nein
den effekt und wieder konditionierung
können placebos auch wirken denn man
weiß dass man nur ein placebo nimmt
deshalb gibt es auch bei vechta folgen
der idee open label placebos also
placebos die klar als solche
gekennzeichnet sind und trotzdem
menschen helfen sollen weil diese idee
gibt es allerdings ein problem und das
heißt extension der körper vergisst mit
der zeit die konditionierung das heißt
je öfter man diese grüne erdbeer wendel
milch ohne wirkstoff zu sich nimmt desto
schwächer geht auch die verknüpfung mit
dem immunsystem professor schidlowski
arbeite daran setzen um diese
konditionierung so lange wie möglich
aufrecht zu erhalten um diesen positiven
effekt zu nutzen
aber alle die jetzt generell nicht gerne
medikamente nehmen müssen verstehen
diese konditionierung funktioniert nicht
ohne echte medikamente
man kann jetzt nicht einfach jemandem
ein placebo geben und sagen diese
tablette wird dann immunsystem hemmen
das funktioniert in diesem fall nicht
durch erwartung das funktioniert nur
durch konditionierung aber placebos
könnten ein toller zusatz sein um die
wirkung von medikamenten zu verbessern
und nicht nur das wir können die wirkung
verstärken als ob die nebenwirkung
reduzierten effekt in kleiner kleiner
defekt sozusagen der böse
zwillingsbruder des placebo effekts nur
zehn effekt bedeutet dass sich durch die
erwartung bestimmter nebenwirkungen
diese nebenwirkungen dann auch
tatsächlich wahrnehmen und man muss
davon ausgehen dass patienten die
richtig diese zeit nehmen müssen wie zb
bei einer chemotherapie das bei denen
zusätzlich zu den echten nebenwirkungen
tatsächlich auch noch eine cd effekt
oben drauf kommt placebo forschung
klingt also vielversprechend
auf dem papier also in den studien aber
ist es auch relevant für die klinische
praxis
ich dann wirklich relevant für die
klinische praxis das wird durchaus
kritisch diskutiert bis persönlich so
dass es jemand ist für die klinische
praxis nicht weil man irgendwelche
patienten mit irgendwelchen zuckertüten
behandelt sondern weil ganz ganz viele
gefunden mittlerweile zeigen dass über
die erwartungen die ich probieren kann
in der kommunikation mit den patienten
das ist da die wirkung von medikamenten
medizinischen behandlung allgemein
verbessern kann und das auftreten oder
sind dann eben durch begrüßt diese
kommunikation mit den patienten
vermeiden kann
und hier kommt der für mich eigentlich
wichtigste punkt ein ausführliches
gespräch mit dem patienten kamen bereits
medizin sein
es hilft dem patienten wenn er die
behandlung und seine krankheit besser
versteht denn der realistische
erwartungen daran hat doch das steht
leider im gegensatz zum alltag in
unserem gesundheitssystem deutsche
hausärzte verbringen im schnitt nur 8
minuten mit ihren patienten und ärzte
sie klar und sich auch immer wieder dass
ihr vergütungssystem ihnen wenig zeit
für patientengespräche lässt die
ergebnisse aus der forschung liegen nahe
dass zeit für den patienten die
sogenannte sprechende medizin kein thema
wohl fühlt extra ist so dann tatsächlich
messbar die behandlung und die wirkungen
der medikamente beeinflussen und
verbessern kann
dank placeboeffekt jahre aus diesem
bereich so ernst muss man muss man das
dann muss man das irgendwo hier muss
sich also noch einiges ändern
man sollte das potenzial des projektes
nicht unterschätzen für uns zu hause für
die patienten und anderen der kilt
allerdings sollten dem placebo-effekt
auch nicht überschätzt er hat auch seine
grenzen der jetzt zb schweres asthma hat
oder eine
mit der allergie sollte bitte keine
placebos zu sich nehmen denn allein eure
subjektive wahrnehmung wird euch nicht
vor schäden schützen ganz zu schweigen
von schweren krankheiten wie eine
lungenentzündung oder krebs da kann die
richtige behandlung natürlich über leben
und tod entscheiden und wenn ihr dann
doch gerne etwas tue ich nehmt das keine
wirkung hat oder dessen wirkung nicht
nachgewiesen ist dann gebt doch
wenigstens kein geld dafür aus das
könnte auch viel günstiger haben meinte
zum beispiel gibt auch wunder freude der
sonne ich habe euch auf jeden fall
bleiben dass da mehr gezeigt und ihr
solltet raten und was in diesem video
geht meine lieblings antwort kommt von
oriel der zwang nur getränke zu trinken
die farblich zur wand passen woher kommt
er warum dritter auf ist er ein
evolutionärer vorteil die verstörendste
antwort kam von julius h wie gesund ist
die blaue milch aus star wars
die metro stars ist grün die sei dass
wir uns schon wieder über blauen
grünstreifen nein es kann sehr gut sein
blau grün das ist so eine sache das
wisst ihr wenn ihr unser video zu fahren
gesehen hat weil sie das noch nicht
gesehen aber schaut euch das unbedingt
an faszinierende sache aber die
gewinnerin ist jannik blum
ich hätte ehrlich gesagt ich gedacht das
ist jemand erkennt aber dass du es
anhand des bildes erkannt dass wirklich
props und kriegszeit und alle anderen
die mit geraten haben es war sehr witzig
dass durchzulesen
wenn ihr auch viel spaß dabei sein wollt
folgende auf instagram wir sehen das
nächste woche und bis dahin plötzlich